rather replace kids oh yeah yeah I
stopped most of the balls in my face I
was a goalie well when your head is that
large yeah it's huge it's like half the
net hi I'm Rob I'm Ryan we are about to
find out how much we know about football
you might call it soccer we have to call
football yeah legally Rob has tips pets
yes okay does that mean I ask first yes
because I want I get to do whatever I
want explain offsides in 11 words or
less nobody knows what offside is nobody
not even the refs yourselves that's
about 11 words
can you demonstrate proper throw in
technique yes like I learned from the
best I learned photos Ben Tozer both
feet have to be behind the line as you
throw you can't even be in the air as
you feel your feet both have to be on
the ground and so that's really it right
there you get this thank you yeah give
an example of a foul that would result
in a straight red card
Spike to the nuts that would do it leads
to the nuts every time
it's not on the car but we'll take it
we'll take it yeah yeah well spitting on
a player yeah denying an obvious goal
scoring opportunity violent conduct
lunging with raised spikes I think that
covers sure spikes in the nuts object or
ball Throne also it doesn't have to be
the nuts what is a football field called
a pitch ding ding ding you got it nailed
it all right here we go 11. well you
know this who is a gaffer the manager
got that my friend how many panels are
there on a traditional soccer ball
I'll give you choices A B C or D a 48 B
16 C 32 d20.
D20
32. according to the official FIFA rule
book how long can the goalkeeper hold
the ball
[Music]
eight seconds very close six seconds
holds the ball for any longer the
opposing team's awarded an indirect free
kick that is wrong what's the difference
between a direct and an indirect free
pick a direct free kick would just be
that the opposing team is not allowed to
interfere with the ball I did not know
this that's incorrect but the answer is
fascinating on a direct kick you can
score by kicking the ball directly into
the goal as Jordan Davies yes Jordan
Davis does from time to time on an
indirect kick you cannot score another
player has to touch the ball first
really
you just watched something happen in
real time the chairman of a football
team just collectively learned a new
emperor the first time or shoes here we
go wreck some specific trivia right now
what year was wrexham FC form 1864.
correct sir 100 correct
who is the current wrexham AFC team
captain
Luke young correct thank you very much
all right this is uh what's the rexham
AFC anthem
uh fearless and devotion Rex Brothers
into promotion wrexham is the name
though uh yeah they call it three listen
devotion I'm gonna put this in the
middle okay put that in the middle okay
yeah uh it's your turn okay yeah that's
fair that's fair no that's the rexim is
the name of the room okay all right good
yeah yeah I can see man of integrity
what is the name of the bar
adjacent to rexin AFC grounds extra
point what is the proprietor's name a
Turf and the proprietor is Wayne Jones
yes before 2022 when was the last time
Wales appeared in the World Cup 1958 and
King hell
is that right Jesus yeah
Rich Welsh Superstar recently signed
with the MLS Club lafc Gareth Bale
correct Garrett Bale which of these four
is not a real Welsh dish
but a breath
creme pogs Cullen skink
leather bread
lever bread Colin's game
Scottish dish oh that's goes out here
which of these is not
a Welsh wordy who
make your near pilipala Tom fat
Ima
um
that's uh Thor's hammer just throw it
away uh that's right
was it really oh it really was Jesus
people
you should know everything about Mark
what creature is on the Welsh flag
dragon which root vegetable did Welsh
soldiers affixed to their helmets in the
16th century in an attempt to tell
friend from foe
we call them tubers and whales but uh
I'm gonna say that was a uh carrot leak
wow [ __ ] me oh Wales has more what per
square mile than any other place in the
world
well okay definitely sheep but also
castles yes I'm giving you that thank
you what is the second most populous
city in Wales the second most populous
city in Wales is going to be part of um
no
what is it this one's all right let's
get Mount Everest is named after a
Welshman Sir George
Everest oh come on for real oh wow
really has a real gimme there I don't
know about that one ask your opponent to
properly use one of the following in a
sentence
foreign
[Music]
Chop Sing or Twitty or duddy
that let's go
[Music]
this great fantastic brilliant Etc
wonderful take that yep uh the Welsh
village of
Ryan go [ __ ] yourself is the second
longest place name in the world how many
syllables does it have you actually know
this
[Music]
is
Jesus Christ
[Music]
yes go get it yo
[Music]
Guru yeah 22 or 23. God damn it amazing
18 syllables but I who cares you get
this card and I'm giving you one of mine
because that was incredible
[Music]
true or false uh there are three times
the amount of sheep than there are
people in Wales boss there are four
times as many sheep as there are people
in Wales I read the back that was the
one that was sitting right there nobody
thought I had to I think that there's
two Hollywood cheaters here I feel like
I've lost
[Music]
oh
I think the people out there are gonna
be happy to see Ryan Reynolds lose it
ah very comfortable losing it you are
you're a great loser you're a great
winner
my favorite flavor it was fun GQ thank
you very much for having us thank you it
was awesome